i don't think we live in a in a world
anymore where
there's one path to drive successful
life
entrepreneurs come from all shapes and
walks of life and we see that
you know daily with companies that that
thrive and companies that
you know perish
[Music]
thank you for joining them 20 minute
leaders how are you i'm doing well how
are you michael good morning
i i'm doing wonderful thank you very
much
uh let's talk about talent let's talk
about the workplace
talent and data driven talent
acquisition and hybrid models because
what you're doing with stroke talent
is is fascinating but but right before
we get there let's go back to your
journey just a little bit from the
tefnion
and finishing 12 years of studies
getting your high school diploma at the
age of 22.
you wouldn't really think that a 22 year
old graduate will end up
being a successful tech veteran what is
that about neither did my parents they
were pretty
concerned when i graduated high school
without a diploma
uh but um you know during high school my
mind was a different place
i didn't enjoy studying although i was
registered to study
physics and computers it was kind of the
you know a great class considered but
my mind was elsewhere i was already
thinking about going the military
service and so i
actually didn't wake up to my final math
test in high school and so i
i never wow i never officially graduated
um i did almost five years in the
military various roles
and when i left i think i was already a
little more mature and understood that
if i wanted to do something with my life
i better complete that by the way the
day that i left the military
i remember my parents calling me like do
you want to double think that
and you don't you won't get any job
outside why do you stick in the military
um and so i did leave the military i
completed my high school diploma i did
my math physics exams
and went and did my um psychometric exam
i guess it's equivalent of an sat i got
a pretty good score
uh kind of you know combined with my
military service paved the way to get
a full three-year scholarship for
computer science
although i never wanted to study
computer science wow i was going to be
boring but
i got a full three-year scholarship um
and that's how i got into computer
science you know one thing led to the
other
and i was never a great engineer
i never thought i will be a great
engineer but it gave me
you know it gave me insights into this
entire
back then you know high-tech industry
what does it mean and there's more than
just coding there's the entire ecosystem
around it
um got to work with a lot of people you
know startup companies large companies
how business get built around software
the various elements that are required
how do you build a product how do you go
sell a product how do you market a
product
and so you know i was fortunate to work
uh from my perspective with the best of
the best
um you know joint companies like mercury
interactive
uh um i was mentored by
leaders um you know probably the best
leaders in the industry people like
uh boss halamis then in vmware
uh with people like paul moritz i was
really um
had the opportunity to learn from these
people how to think about business how
to think about leading people what
what should you focus on what should you
give up on uh
what to insist and you know would you
would you do anything differently going
if you were to go back
to high school middle school would you
would you do anything differently
uh you know i'm not sure
um yes you might say i wasted some time
but
i don't think anything could have been
different some things need to happen at
their own pace
uh the only thing i i regret is i never
graduated uh a flight school other than
that i don't really care about anything
else
um you know my kids now have three kids
now uh only their
uh teams and and although school is
important we never
really look at their grades i don't
really make it uh
make it a thing i think that there's so
much more to driving
successful happy life than you know how
much you scored on your
english math or whatever exam i think
that you know i'm
i'm leaving testimony to someone that
flunked math in school
um i mean you know my parents were
called into school multiple times
it just took some time for me to get
settled in and
you know to find my way and i think that
the most important thing is to find
um how should i say it try find your
passion
be a good person and beyond that i mean
there's
multiple things that need to be done i
don't think we live in a in a world
anymore where there's one path to drive
successful life
entrepreneurs come from all shapes and
walks of life and we see that
you know daily with companies that that
thrive and companies that
you know perish um and there's no one
path for that it's not you have to go to
these schools and you have to
study these things and you have to take
this track it's mostly about
the person you are the interaction that
you're able to create with others
your ability to think outside the box i
think that a lot of these things
are not things that you require in
traditional
education but you acquire them through
different experiences in life
which by the way would lead to some of
my observation around where the talent
market is heading
a lot of who i am today is that is going
to be my next question obviously it's
not because what i've studied at school
but it's because of the experiences i
had both you know at school and then
uh in my military service with the
people i had the opportunity to interact
with
them being fortunate to work for the
companies with the people i i worked
with and how much
i was open to learn from them to get
feedback to do better at what i do and
it's not specifically about getting this
great or that great it's
one of the things you study in
israeli air forces doesn't matter
how successful your last flight was it's
like can you come off that flight
spend time to research what was wrong
research what went well
keep what went well and fix what went
wrong for your next flight and then on
an ongoing basis how do you create
ongoing improvement and no i think
without applying this specific approach
on a day-to-day basis
but this was the mentality that i've
absorbed over the last
20 years you know sometimes i succeed in
what i did
a lot of times i failed you know i built
products didn't succeed
i built products that were extremely
successful but how do you what do you
what can you learn from it
right um i think one of the things that
i was always so
hugely impressed uh doing during my
service and
and we were i was always looking at the
air force the briefing
methodology that you're referring to and
i think that it's been quoted countless
times by eric schmidt and
sam altman and others they were talking
about this this behavior
mechanism where it doesn't matter you
succeeded or failed or failed
there's always something to learn from
this experience and unless you you're
very intentional with the way that you
debrief
this experience you can let the lessons
just fly by you
and and then it's worthless because you
didn't learn anything right then where's
the compounding learning
along your life and i agree it's so
important there
and it's that the brief and one of the
most important things with that debrief
is
how do you debrief leaving your ego
aside because we have this
uh this internal defensive mechanism
it's like it wasn't me something else
went wrong
and you know and i met at some point
it wasn't in my unit but you know one of
the elite units in the military
had a friend that kind of told me so the
first thing you did in the brief it's
like
you go up on stage and say i failed i
was wrong once you do that you come with
that approach
then you know your egos decide and then
you learn and evolve
and i try to apply that and you know and
then moving on it's like it's
15 years later i heard palmer rates back
at vmware which
he's one of the nicest person one of the
smartest person people that i know and
he said
um how do you grow up as a leader not
spending
every minute at work trying to be the
smartest person in the room
how do you leave that aside it's like
doesn't matter who's right who's wrong
how do you conversation in a different
manner and i think
um some of it has to do with maturity
something has to do with obviously
attitude and dna but once you you rise
to that level of not really
putting yourself at the center but
you're just a piece of that puzzle
a lot of things uh inside and around you
start moving a lot better
and i think that that's a that's that's
very very smart and i'm definitely
thinking that too hard
tell me a little bit about your your
insights into the talent
space what is the town space to start
with because i don't need many
entrepreneurs that are working in that
space
yeah um so i'll tell you my obviously my
pov so you know i spent 20 years almost
in the industry
leading teams you know hundreds of
people in in some of those phases
and the one thing that you see along the
line is the one thing that i think
distinguishes
super successful companies with less
successful companies
is the ability to deploy the right
talent at the right project at the right
time to
uh to produce the right results um and
what i've seen and i've worked with
corporate small companies is that it's
very difficult to
navigate this talent pool because the
resources that you need are not the
resources that you have and then you
start doing
you know all this maneuvering uh instead
of fitting the business fitting your
existing talent pool
um back in 2013 when i moved back to
israel from california
i started my own company and we
bootstrapped because we couldn't raise
any any money
and we started using online marketplaces
it was early days for fiverr odesk was
still the lean platform i think
we started getting exposure to yeah or
online marketplace where you can find
talent
um after a bit of a trial and error
because it gets time to get adjusted to
this
we found tremendous value in online
platforms because
all of a sudden if i need something i
have someone working on it the next day
maybe they're not perfect for it
but if i had to go and recruit for right
i'm going to do that job i'd be waiting
three months
now i get something seven percent the
quality starts working on it within
48 hours and that kind of change
even less yeah it depends what you need
right if you need a piece of code then
sometimes you need to
qualify them and and so forth but it
kind of changed our entire month so we
built a company
uh that started getting traction at some
point we decided to drop it
but it wasn't because we weren't able to
execute at some point with 18 people
working from us
for us all the way from new york new
rochester all the way to india
bangladesh indonesia all over the world
we're 18 people working for us from
design to coding
and we found that the ability to execute
grows exponentially when you when you
adopt that approach
further on i joined back into the
corporate life and trying to apply that
approach into corporate
didn't work corporates work on a
different agents
different processes and and i
found that to be a disabler for
companies
to uh um get to their full potential
and we kind of said what if we can
connect this world
of infinite talent pools because really
there's hundreds of millions
highly qualified people around the world
wanting to freelance on the other end
there is need for talent
how do we can connect the two together
not through the traditional marketplace
that exists now
right now which is more of a consumer
base swipe your credit card get someone
to do work
but really in a robust manner for what
uh um
what corporates need to do um
so we embarked on this journey to say
what if we built
an enterprise grade mechanism that helps
companies
a take control over their existing
freelancers and contractors and b
augment their existing execution
processes
with uh with external freelancers the
biggest challenge that we saw out there
was the internal organizational
processes for companies unlike
uh consumers require a different process
because you know michael if you need
someone to do slides for you or get a
video for you swipe your credit card on
fiverr
some will do that for you if you want to
do that within hippo for example
do you have the budget do you have the
permissions do you know which paperwork
these freelancers need to sign can you
assure that ip
will be owned by hippo at the end of the
process there's a set of questions that
come with it
that the company has to comply with to
be able to take
right to take that value the
best example i can give is think about
amazon 12 years ago you're young you're
far younger than i am so i don't know
where you were when amazon emerged back
in 2007 give or take 2008
but when amazon started up until that
point if you wanted to build an
application at a company
you needed to get servers to get a
server
you need to go to i.t it sent you back
to finance
to get budget approval then you went
back to it that gave you the spec that
they can support then you went and
submitted the purchase order
six weeks later you had a server and you
could start coding
the day after amazon emerged if you
wanted to build an application all you
do is click a few buttons
what is changing the profile you know i
think that actually for that that exact
different you know i experienced that
being you know in the 800 units where
you know it's it's on-prem and
it's it's still it's it's not that we
have today and then a day after
you know getting out of it all of a
sudden you have everything in the click
of a button so that mental shock
what you've experienced i think over 12
years i've experienced in one day
but i think that's just the nature of of
the difference i agree
and if you think about it the biggest
difference
i mean it doesn't it's not that app
something's far cheaper but there's two
significant differences
number one everything that you do on
amazon
is fully tracked so it's digitized you
click a button you bought
someone sees it right someone can
monitor it someone can come to you and
say hey michael did you buy this service
everything is fully visible nothing goes
in it the other thing everything that
you bought today you can decide you
don't need tomorrow and return it
the same thing is now happening in the
world with talent
if you need someone to help you i don't
know what what part of hippa you're
working on if you need someone an expert
in nlp tomorrow
help you solve a problem you can go find
someone to help you solve the nlp
problem it's gonna cost you a few
hundred dollars he's gonna accelerate
your work by three four days
and then you let him go it's the same
exact thought process everything is
managed
just like but like you're mentioning
there's a whole added layer of
complexity because it's not just the
expertise but there's compliance issues
with the data that we're working with
and there is the you know a lot of it is
based around the privacy and the
intellectual property of the company
and i'm assuming that with an example
like you're giving if you're requesting
the aid of an expert
ad hoc then this is probably dealing
with some
sensitive data or like some core
business that you really need to dig
deep and therefore you also need to be
extra careful with who you're supporting
information
that's a great comment and this is
exactly where so comes in part of what
stoke
built because we're optimized for these
corporates and companies
is to help the company set their
policies who's allowed to be a free
company what paperwork do they need to
sign which states can they come from
what validation and background check
will the platform run
on them before they get started all of
that in a fully automated manner
the example another example i can give
you is think about when you're traveling
uh you know between stanford and tel
aviv and wherever it is
you're going and if you're going on on a
private trip you're booking your flight
through
i know expedia or or booking or uh
whatever platform you're using for your
personal life if you're booking a trip
through depot
you're probably doing it using our trip
actions
right of that sort the difference is at
the end of the day everyone's boarding
the same
flight but the internal controls
mechanisms validations policies
budgeting
all of that is different between a
personal trip and a corporate trip
and this is where the corporate element
of handling talent and freelancer
is the layer that stoke has built to
make sure that everyone's working for
the company
is valid everyone is legal now with ab5
or prop 22 in california make sure that
they can actually be paid as an
independent contractor making sure you
find the right id
document so you own your ip at the end
of the process make sure they got paid
on time so you're not violating uh
payment
legislation this is exactly the layer
that we add
so if you or anyone else in the company
needs to get
extra help or resources they don't have
to go through
legal finance hr procurement and wait
for months before they can actually get
going
how do you actually create that
marketplace where because it sounds like
the onboarding for these contractors you
can call them as well as the companies
is not a one one click right i mean you
have to you know vet
by the person you have to make sure that
they're they have compliance with all
the taxes and all the payment methods
and you also have to make sure that
they're also
sending the right iep contract so it
does sound complicated how do you
simplify
the process for both the contractor and
the company that
contributes a great question there's two
sides a we're not trying to become a
marketplace ourselves i'm not pulling
the talents myself
most of the companies we work with start
off by bringing on their own talents for
the platform the freelancers
that they're working with right now just
to make sure that they
are complying with legislation and if
the companies look
for additional resources then we're
actually partnering
with this other marketplace there's
about six or seven hundred marketplaces
now
um hbs just released the paper there's
over 700 marketplaces
you know some of them generic like
upward freelancer.com fiverr
some of them are more specific uh or
verticalized
from our standpoint we're not we're not
taking a dime off the freelancer
so for us we're okay working with anyone
a marketplace in partnership
when someone's searching for talent will
go searches for multiple marketplaces
and when the connection is done between
the company
and the freelancer will make sure that
we vet the freelancer we make them sign
the right people work everything is
happening automatically
through the platform so the work will
not start before all that background
check he's wrong
that makes a lot of sense i'd love to
spend the last few minutes that we have
talking a little bit about
your observation on the talent industry
as covet hit so everybody's talking
about working remotely you know
we hear that sentence every other day
but
but i'm curious to hear with your
outlook on on the hybrid model
and not just onboarding employees during
cover but also onboarding freelancers
and i'm assuming
intuitively that there has been an
increase in usage
of freelancers and and i'm guessing that
a lot of companies are realizing
that okay if i'm if i'm finding people
online maybe i don't have to find the
person that's sitting in
in the next street maybe i can just hire
the person that is you know 1 000
kilometers away but it's a little bit
cheaper
or has a different skill set so what
what has happened
to your industry as a result so first of
all the
the trend was there way before covet
started uh
there was a report from 2018 uh in the
united states there were 2 500 companies
without offices in 2018. so this is not
new
the this remote thing didn't start with
coving what cove
if you look at the the report from the
irs and
bureau of labor statistics the pro the
projection was that by 2025
50 of uh workforce in the us will be
freelancing and by 20 30 60
and though the trajectory is there this
is this is way before
wow what covet has done is accelerated a
five-year process
into five months and all the indications
that we're seeing by public companies
like fiverr and upwork
uh by gartner mckinsey deloitte cnbc and
harvard now is that we're seeing
20 to 30 percent depends on who you're
quoting uh
growth in the number of freelancers by
these companies
there's two main problems there number
one everyone's remote
so does it matter if i get someone to
work remote from for me
on payroll or as a freelancer obviously
there's a lot of benefit
in working as a freelancer it doesn't
matter if they're on payroll or not
add to that the fact generational shift
most of uh generation z
um and a portion of millennials prefer
to be freelancers not to be tied to a
single employer
then there's a match of expectation
companies prefer that flexibility
individuals prefer that flexibility
because no one expects job security
anymore anyway so why not have that
flexibility
um and and the last thing
is that um companies are realizing
that it's super complicated to run any
projection
they don't know how they're going what's
going to happen next year so getting
into commitment with full-time employees
versus
keeping flexibility in a world of
changing skill sets
there is expectation that skill sets
will change every two to three years
and so do i really need to spend now
getting people on board
that will be with me in four to five
years maybe it's not the right thing for
the company anymore
we're seeing uh um right uh average time
uh tech employees spending the companies
has dropped to 1.9
years she's under two years if you think
about it that's the average time someone
sticks to the company
so why not build a flexible workforce
that has
60 70 percent of its employees as
full-time employees and the other 30-40
percent
keeps changing on an ongoing basis every
research shows
freelancers are more up to date with
changes in the industry
they're more passionate about what they
do they execute faster
and the onboard three times faster
compared to traditional employees
because they're doing it constantly wow
so if that's the case
take on freelancers start working with
them
if they're great at what they do try to
convince them to become full-time
employees
and if they don't get someone else
i think that uh that's a an amazing way
to end
uh and i'm i'm convinced uh so
thank you very very much for this time
thank you for for teaching a little bit
more than
and then a lot more than i knew about
about this industry and i think the way
you're doing at stoke town it makes
perfect sense to me
especially with the trajectories of
warburg going and kobe 19 as we said it
just accelerated it
the trend was already there i've been
actually using odesk
since 2013 when i had my high school
startup
we had almost 50 people in india and
pakistan that were working
ad hoc on all these various tasks
because we were for
high schoolers and we needed more
support and we didn't even know how to
get
real employees but it was very easy to
swipe a credit card and pay somebody
from odesk
and i wish we had stoke back then so if
my co-founders are listening to this
uh you they know exactly that what i'm
talking about
before we leave i have to ask you for
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
um i'd start with um
assertive uh empathetic
and
visionary although it sounds like you
know i'm i'm uh i'm a bit exaggerating
about myself but that's
that's how usually i approach things you
look at the long planner now
i i love that i like and it comes
definitely across in this conversation
that a lot of a lot of it is long-term
thinking and and i love that
say one thing and you know as a tip for
others it's like
empathy is keys like it doesn't matter
what you do and how you're trying to
build it
uh and you know you're working for uh
for hippo and
and assaf is a great example of beyond
you know the visionary and the leader
and he's one of the smartest people i
know
it's like the first thing is uh be a a
mensch
uh in the edition it's like be a decent
person be a kind person
uh everything else uh you know is gravy
i'm very excited to send this to him now
thank you very very much and stay safe
and stay healthy